[Música]
al salir el sol sobre Lisboa puede
comenzar la distribución diaria en este
Barrio Obrero de la capital
[Música]
estos drogadictos acuden aquí cada
mañana
para recibir su dosis de metadona
son adictos a la heroína y necesitan
esta medicación para evitar el síndrome
de abstinencia
buen día
vengo aquí todas las mañanas a la misma
hora
es como el trabajo es mi responsabilidad
este tratamiento médico para toxicómanos
financiado por el estado y administrado
completamente al aire libre se ha
convertido en una normalidad cotidiana
también se realizan chequeos médicos
algo muy valioso para esta paciente de
16 años no solo la metadona y la
situación de la heroína
también es el mensaje para la vida
el apoyo el cuidado del amor es muy
importante durante 20 años la política
antidroga portuguesa ha ido un paso por
delante del resto del mundo filmada en
2000 esta misma zona solía apodarse el
supermercado de la droga en aquella
época el 1% de toda la población
portuguesa era adicta a la heroína para
contener el problema el país tomó la
medida sin precedentes de despenalizar
todas las drogas hoy en día si paran a
un individuo con una pequeña cantidad de
droga no lo llevan a la estación de
policía sino a este edificio esta mujer
estaba en posesión de unos gramos de
cocaína
toma estas drogas por inhalación o
fumándolas
por inhalación no hay entrevista
policial este agente del Ministerio de
sanidad solo intenta comprender las
circunstancias personales de esta
consumidora de drogas no es un tribunal
es un diálogo abierto entre dos personas
así que la conversación es muy poco
moralista
mi propósito y mi objetivo es que cuando
se vayan sepan que pueden volver
esta consumidora ocasional de drogas
sale sin que se le imputen cargos como
ella 2500 toxicómanos son escuchados
cada año en esta comisión de disuasión a
la mayoría no se les impone ninguna
sanción siempre que no recaigan a otros
se les orienta hacia el tratamiento los
consumidores de drogas ya no son
tratados como delincuentes sino como
pacientes si se considera que está
funcionando solo si la gente se abstiene
después de ser capturada probablemente
no esté funcionando muy bien pero yo
diría que todas estas personas cuando
salieron de la comisión de disuasión
estaban en posesión información sobre la
sustancia sobre el riesgo asociado al
consumo
este planteamiento basado en la salud
parece funcionar actualmente hay tres
veces menos adictos a la heroína en
Portugal que hace 20 años el número de
muertos por sobredosis se acercaba a la
media de la ue en 2001 ahora es cuatro
veces menor Pero se trata de un éxito
frágil la demanda de otras drogas como
el crack va en aumento la política
antidroga portuguesa tiene que dar un
giro este centro de consumo de drogas de
bajo riesgo acaba de abrir sus puertas
pero ya se ha quedado pequeño
cuando se planificó pensábamos que a
finales de año tendríamos 200 o 300
usuarios
2021 en realidad desde mayo hemos tenido
más de 900 la política antidroga de
Portugal puede estar sometida a cierta
tensión Pero sigue siendo una de las más
acertadas en comparación con otras
administraciones del mundo algunos de
ellos como Noruega y algunos estados de
Estados Unidos se inspiran en las
prácticas vanguardistas de Portugal para
adaptar su propia política